[Applause]
I feel like we look like we belong
together
we do
yeah like we're suited for each other
pun intended same okay okay first of all
people love shit's creek so much that
they named their dogs after you and your
character
well we actually have pictures
that's a Stevie oh my God that's two
dogs that's two dogs that's a Stevie and
a David I haven't had an Oscar or an
Emmy or anything but I know that that's
better
so with you I'll take a dog over to
Warren anything
um okay
ask me sometimes like have you taken
something from a set did you save
anything and I my answer is like always
no which is so lame and boring and I've
I haven't gotten I just haven't taken
anything from sets my answer is
everything wait what did you take okay
so I took well first of all I think I
should preface this with at the end of
Creek
um everyone was allowed to take an
outfit because all the outfits were very
expensive designer Brands and I was like
um my outfits are like I brought from
home they're they're literally mine so I
don't think this is fair at all right
um so I took the giant stag painting
behind Stevie's desk really yes I also
took I did this that's the beginning
um I took um oh we'll make these are all
my things these are all my things this
is my Stevie name tag oh my gosh TV name
tag this is
this is this is my keychain it's this
this is to the Roses um room in the
motel oh God
I'm so sorry these are all my things I
love okay we just went into your place
and stole them so okay so you're okay
with stealing from my place yes exactly
yeah I felt like fair game this is um Mr
Rose's really successful book that he
did and he'd put like too Stevie that is
so cool this is my favorite thing ever
because this is the Cabaret play villain
like look at Moira and that's me this is
so cool yeah God I have got to start
stealing stuff right yeah so from now on
I'm gonna steal okay great okay I want
to steal this book because I'm so into
it so will you tell us about this book
because I am obsessed with the premise
so um it's Amelia earwood basic witch
and the book came about when I was I was
watching the Kardashians as one does and
um I just was watching it being like
because they're a real family and I'm
like if I just happen to be born in that
family
I would be the worst Kardashian they
would like kick me off the show so I was
like what if there was one sister who
was
kicked out like who's never in the show
that we don't know about because she was
such a bad
you influencer person and um so that's
how this came about Emilia is the least
favorite daughter of her famous witch
family I think like the Witch dashians
and but the Kardashians are witches well
they're witches right yeah because
because
they're witches right nice witches very
nice magical witches yes there are no
way strainers like I watched the
Kardashians or see them I don't come up
with this this is brilliant
this is so fun
now is it true that like before you go
to bed there's something that you do
I mean that sounds worse than the thing
I do
or it could sound better maybe I mean I
do it I do go to sleep to murder podcast
yeah yes but I have a theory I have a
theory because if I'm listening to a
murder podcast I'm not gonna get
murdered that would be crazy that would
be that would right I think you're right
right if you're doing it then it can't
happen if you got murdered listening to
a murder podcast that would be so like
not it's like lightning doesn't Strike
Back plane and I just want to be like
you
um I want to steal things I want to come
up with
um
I I actually would um like to present
you with a gift it's a teddy bear so
that when you learn listen to your
murder podcast
oh my God
[Applause]
oh my God this is the greatest thing
ever oh my gosh thank you it's a
screaming teddy bear
[Applause]
now
everybody check out Emily Hampshire
Emily's book Amelia Airwood basic witch
goes on sale everywhere tomorrow I love
the concept I think it is so fresh and
so fun
foreign
[Music]